I'm looking for a place to eat lunch with three people
m I just made a comment without permission
Hey pesticide
Saki-san
[Music]
[Applause]
Somewhere good place
Coupler and Lee are like places that are not popular at school
I used to be alone in junior high school, so
[Music]
taroo Let's go there
anyway.
I clean the toilets for negotiations, etc. Not only
that, no one
has used it for lunch break, so
there is no other person. Leisure I put in
the back of the toilet and the dismissed car
pano.
I don't have a witch. I understand that it doesn't
smell a little more. I wonder if the toilet for club activities is relatively clean and has little smell.
That's why
I was careful about the pen on the day
Gay enough
I wonder what the way is doing in the toilet, isn't it?